[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous
enseignantes et enseignants parents
d'élèves également tous les jours
partout en france je le sais vous
transmettez avec bonheur le goût et le
plaisir d'apprendre
vous le savez à ma manière je me glisse
souvent dans vos pas en réalisant des
expériences dans mon atelier des
expériences spectaculaires qui constitue
un excellent support à la compréhension
des phénomènes le fonctionnement des
volcans et l'action du sel sur la glace
par exemple mais rien de tel pour piquer
encore plus notre curiosité notre goût
du savoir que de lui offrir un cadre
plus large dans une salle de classe à
ciel ouvert les journées sont rythmées
par des activités ludo-éducatives la
nature se donne en spectacle sous nos
yeux
elle vit et c'est le réel qui
l'emportent sur le virtuel
du coup nous aussi nous allons quitter
ses murs direction ou vergne rhône-alpes
et vivre notre classe grandeur nature à
la montagne je vous propose un nouveau
programme pour partir à la découverte de
cette région et de ses richesses
naturelles
qui sait peut-être donnera-t-il des
envier à certaines ou certains d'entre
vous dix partis en classe découverte
en attendant pour échanger je compte sur
vous pour ne pas partager les plus
belles expériences que vous mettez en
oeuvre avec vos élèves qu'elles soient
réalisées pleine nature ou en classe je
vous en dirai davantage dans les
semaines à venir de mon atelier à la
montagne il n'y a qu'un pas que je me
réjouis de franchir avec la classe
grandeur nature alors vous me suivez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]